with cyberpunk releasing soon in
november and the releases of the new
lore book the world of cyberpunk 2077
i thought it would catch everyone here
up to speed on the timeline of cyberpunk
before we start though i do forget
introductions from time to time
my name is jinji and i plan on uploading
high quality videos on all there is to
know about the cyberpunk lore from now
until when the game of course releases
in november where we get loads of new
information the main focus of the
content will be about the story and lore
of cyberpunk with videos like this one
so if that sounds interesting then
consider subscribing and sticking around
but with the introduction done let's
delve into the timeline of cyberpunk and
the origin of night city
timestamps will be provided in the
description for users who want to skip
ahead to certain parts
now there is lots of different timelines
and alternate paths within the cyberpunk
universe but cyberpunk 2077 follows the
3.0 timeline from the role-playing game
cyberpunk in the dark future
but while it follows that timeline it
also takes a slight detour from it as
well
even with that timeline different things
happen in other different continents
around the world so
we're going to try to primarily focus on
the united states as that's where night
city is located
to make sure information is accurate
though we're going to be referencing the
new lore book that just released
the world of cyberpunk 2077 which should
give us a detailed look at what is
happening
so a lot of the stuff in the beginning
of america is actually the same the cold
war the declaration of independence the
world wars so
none of those dates and actions have
changed but eventually america was
separated
from the new united states and the free
states a few states stepped away and
seceded from the united states just like
back in the civil war
those states were alaska nevada north
california south california
republic of texas and utah in this
universe there are 51 states the reason
we have 51 is because like stated
previously california has split into two
north and south
between the years of 1990 and 2016
three corporate wars started within the
time span the first corporate war was
between orbital air
ebm and a bunch of other companies this
first corporate war wasn't crazy but it
was an example to other corporations
that using wholesale military-style
warfare against one another
was a viable business practice the first
corporate war was the first conflict of
its kind and led to other corporations
following suit and massive conflicts
with each other over resources and
business prospects
this was then of course followed by the
second and third corporate wars
thanks to these these mega corporations
were gaining even more power than before
some even more powerful than the current
world governments
affiliations between politicians and
corporations ceased to be things
regarded as conflict of interest
and were now treated as advantageous to
the world of big business and politics
thanks to this though companies had
access to all of the world's natural
resources of course environmental
collapse and climate change were
inevitable
acid rain and deforestation soon became
america's biggest
problem while natural disasters were
happening there was also political
disasters like the thermonuclear war
that took place in the middle east
which turned the middle east into
chernobyl which caused a global oil
crisis
the united states government tried to
cover this situation up by manipulating
the stock markets of
america and europe but it backfired as
this info was then leaked to the public
worldwide a financial meltdown shook the
economies of almost every single country
on the earth which allowed the
corporations to gain even more power
since the governments were crippling and
the companies were rising
the american government then created a
coup of sorts called the gang of four
which is an organization being comprised
of the nsa the cia
the fbi and the dea which ended
democracy as we know it
as most members could do whatever they
wanted whenever they wanted as long as
they were part of the gang of four
this is where some of the states started
to secede as we previously stated
a new social class was then also formed
called nomads which were migrants who
searched for water
jobs and safety from the constant
political turmoil another instance that
created nomads was in 1994. i know we're
jumping back a slight bit but i thought
it would fit here
in 1994 the stock market crashed this
was named the collapse which killed
roughly 100 million americans thanks to
plagues
mutated viruses terrorist nuclear
attacks and complete ecological collapse
most people stated that the collapse was
the worst catastrophe of the 21st
century
now we enter the 2020s 100 million
people are dead within 15 years due to
the collapse
the country could still operate but not
in the way that it's accustomed to
all the states hoarded their own
resources from others and closed the
borders making the country even more
divided than it already was
and to top it all off the fourth
corporate war has started in 2021. this
was a war between two aqua tech agencies
sino and otech which tried to get
control over the remains of a third
corporation the iha to help this ceno
hired militech and otech hired arasaka a
name we're going to be talking about
very very much throughout the rest of
this video both of these two were mega
corporations
militech specialized in weapons in
private military while arasaka dealt
with corporate security banking and
manufacturing
the two companies in the beginning of
this war were doing more secret attacks
and more data stealing and finding dirty
information
this was the first stage of the war
known as the ocean war which by the
early months of 2022
transitioned into the second phase
called the shadow war as there was a new
struggle between the two megacorps
previously mentioned
this is where actual killing took place
mercenaries and edgerunners would join
both sides to capitalize on the war
by making a quick buck but it got even
worse as some people started using the
net
to send viral programs into people and
having the code operate
long after their death this left many
areas of the net irreparable and
dangerous
the net for a quick summary is similar
yet different to the current internet
that we use now
it's a much more extensive operation
including appliances and cybernetic
limbs and it's made up of hard lines
radio links cell networks
microtransmitters pretty much anything
that can send info from one computer to
another
that's how it works to access the net
all you need is a simple modem which
will do the trick
and you can experience the net as we do
with computers using tablets or just a
keyboard and mouse as usual
but some people like to use the 3d
aspect called cyber modem
these people are considered netrunners
lots of stuff exist in here like
programs
ais other people advanced algorithms and
data fortresses but even this wasn't
enough to stop the two corporations as
they entered the third stage
the hot war this became full-scale war
cities were now reduced to rubble
innocent civilians were dead
or refugees thanks to this global trades
were immediately halted
international trade routes became war
zones and piracy of content was at an
all-time high
at this time the only thing saving the
net was netwatch an organization whose
focus was protecting the net from
netrunners
but it was too much to handle thanks to
the destruction of global servers and
data banks while also being ravaged by
swarms of malicious codes and viruses
and demon class programs
the nets slowly died because of this one
of the arasaka towers within night city
was actually blown up
and wiped out by a nuclear weapon dead
knitted by some mercenaries
it's unclear who did this but some
believe it was the atlantis group
compromised of
rogue morgan blackhand and johnny
silverhand
but thanks to the other international
countries withdrawing support from the
two
while also being attacked by some free
states militech ended up emerging
victorious in 2023 but they were just as
almost crippled
as the rivals were 2024 to 2035 was
post-fourth corporate war
it didn't start great as rebellions and
riots emerged pretty quickly in just
about every corner of the earth
in the u.s a new president elizabeth
cress was elected and declared
martial law and the parts of the u.s
that remain under executive control
society still wanted an explanation for
the previous bombing we mentioned
earlier but no answer was found
but the corporations involved in the war
were still on a tight leash as they were
considered suspects
at this time though corporations were
decreasing in power and governments were
more focusing on internal affairs
suppressing civil arrest
and rebuilding the country so no
technological advancements were
happening at this time
nomads were also becoming extremely
popular as they would scavenge
battlefields to find some tech that
people would want and pawn them off to
them
and while this sounds all great the
issue is that kress doesn't really like
the free states she did nothing to help
night city after the bombing hoping to
bring the free state of north california
back to the original united states but
they refused so they attempted to
rebuild on their own
after that netwatch created black wall
so they could block humans from is
controlled regions of the old net
and fast forward just a little bit and
were part of the unification era which
takes place in 2035
and 2069. these 35 years were slow but a
good turn in rebuilding the world's
nations and corporations
cities were being rebuilt and trade
routes were being opened up again
during this time many states that were
abandoned during the collapse were being
brought up thanks to government and
corporate aid
the corporations used this opportunity
to make amends to get rid of the
negative public opinion they had against
them
night city was also being rebuilt by
nomads and smaller corporations as once
again previously stated
they had no help from president
elizabeth cress the net was also less
available to the public and harder for
net runners to penetrate
but all good things must come to an end
as we hit 2070
the start of the metal wars in 2070
president rosalind meyers attempted to
gain control of the free states by
presenting a unification
program the states all denied and
conflict started again
the new united states declared war on
the free states but states including
colorado new mexico
wyoming montana arizona nevada and north
carolina
all remained neutral on the conflict but
had to pay some little concessions to
the federal government
arasaka ended up joining the fight again
and originally not being known that they
were in the fights
ended up backing up the free states but
were beat pretty hard by the nusa
or new united states forces night city
was part of north california so
they tried not to fight in the war and
thanks to councilman lucius rein
he prevented the nusa from even entering
the city because he signed a deal with
arasaka who launched a super carrier to
protect them from intruders
once the nusa saw they immediately
withdrew this war finally did end though
thanks to the treaty of unification side
by both sides the free states remained
how they were before and agreed to
participate in government affairs
this treaty was made due to president
meyers worried that they wouldn't have
the numbers to win thanks to arasaka's
involvement with the free states and
didn't want to escalate things back to
how they were 40 years ago no one liked
the treaty but it was vital to stop the
war and prevent a global crisis
so they accept it anyway night city also
became an international free city now
not under the rule of the new united
states or the free state essentially its
own governing body
companies pumped loads of money into the
city so they get a foothold in the newly
built and completely free city
night city also allowed arasaka to
rebuild its headquarters which was the
one that was bombed in 2023
night city was prospering but not
everyone liked it though and now we're
at 2077
and caught up currently in today's time
climate change is at an all-time high
hurricanes and tornadoes are more
frequent and deadlier than before
killing tons of people in the process
haiti ended up being abandoned in 2062
and the destruction caused in the
caribbean islands once considered the
worst natural disaster in the 21st
century desertification and drought are
even more dangerous in the united states
in the areas around it
clean water is scarce and flooding has
gotten worse and has especially impacted
la and parts of night city
on top of this because of cyber
technology this led to a new mental
illness cyberpsychosis which made the
user isolate themselves from society
until they could not take the lack of
human interaction anymore and became
violent
not much is known about the mental
illness but some scientists believe it
has to do with the quantity of
cybernetics
a person has but this isn't factual
information as more testing is
definitely required
we are now officially caught up to
present day night city
but this of course it doesn't answer the
origins of night city
so allow me to explain night city began
in 1994
the same year that the stock market had
crashed by an entrepreneur named
richard knight knight had split off from
his original partners halsey and ferris
to start a new company called knight
international
he then bought an entire town called
morro bay which is located near the
border which divides north and south
california and attempted to turn it into
a full-fledged city
a place that was safe clean and free
from crime poverty and chaos which he
called
coronado city things were going pretty
well in the beginning as big businesses
were lured in with the promises of tax
benefits if they invested
but nike wouldn't see the creation to
the end as he was murdered four years
into the development it's unclear who
killed him but some say it was crime
organizations who were allied with
construction firms that had been
excluded from knight's plan
coronado's leadership was actually then
held by crime syndicates for some time
assault drug trafficking cyber terrorism
and prostitution were then commonplace
and then they officially changed the
name to night city
in memory of richard knight which is
pretty disrespectful after all the havoc
they caused once he died eventually the
corporations got annoyed with all the
turmoil happening and ended up pushing
back on their own
and almost every single crime syndicate
member was dead in night city within a
few days
the rest of it as displayed in the book
is a bit just more of a quick zoom
through of what happened with night city
then where they had a quick golden age
in 2020
the arasaka headquarters bombing in 2023
and then after that for the next decade
or so which is rebuilding the city up
until 2040
and then of course the meta wars
happening in 2070. within night city
though there is six different districts
watson westbrook city center haywood
santo domingo and pacifica
and as much as i would love to delve
deep into each of these places as they
are very unique to one another they'll
probably be their own dedicated video
which we'll do in the future
and that about wraps it up for today's
video as the rest of the book then
discusses things about night city like
social status
law enforcement weaponry and
entertainment which while this info is
fantastic
this video was more about everything
leading up to present day at night city
to get the average player not extremely
well versed in the cyberpunk story up to
speed
this book has too much information
practically and i think it would be a
disservice to not use it again so expect
some videos about cyberpunk again
in the near future but yeah let me know
what you guys think about the story of
night city in the story of cyberpunk
once again this video was mainly for the
people that wanted to understand
how night city got to the way it was and
what the cyberpunk universe is all about
as of course it is very different from
our modern day
timeline that we exist in right now let
me know what you guys think about the
video in the comments below let me know
any other topics you want me to delve
into if you totally want me to do that i
gladly will
and with that like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new and take care
i'll see you in a future video peace out
[Music]
you